his name is Baron Davis aka bar oatmeal
there you go yeah yeah I believe get a
bow
um well first of all I just want to give
you props because uh I'm a basketball
fanatic and you were one of my favorite
players to ever watch I remember when
you got drafted by the Hornets like
watching like yeah them early Hornet
stays man you was like a [__] you
were just like a shot of energy in the
league like
your size could dunk on everybody like
man yeah you have to you know you have
to come in the league back then like you
have to make a name for yourself you
know what I mean you coming in a league
with you know you got Juggernaut steel
you got stocktons and Malone's yeah like
because when you get drafted 99.99 yeah
yeah so that's like yeah Penny was still
around uh for everybody everybody was
just coming into his own Steve Nash just
was coming into his own so it was like
the the it was kind of before the wild
point guard Renaissance yeah yeah you
know like mid 2000 like 2010 I would say
we had a hell of a point guard
Renaissance so my air is pretty you know
well I mean yeah I mean especially I
think that was a start because you were
coming in while a lot of those guys like
Stockton yeah on the traditional point
guards Mark Jackson we're going out yeah
Mark Jackson was a poster point guard
Ross Strickland was to get to the whole
type of point guard so they was okay I
was there yeah I was in his prime now I
still don't know because I hear people
consider him okay he's more of a
shooting he was a shooting guard on that
team Eric snow was the point guard yeah
he was a scoring guard I remember those
battles man you against that dude he was
sick yeah
um yo I wanted to talk to you because I
feel like correct me if I'm wrong I
remember seeing something when I was
like younger when you were uh in the
league were you throwing up your
neighborhood like ever on video like
when you were like making shots and [__]
because that never happened no okay
because I wanted to ask you about how
you feel about the driving rant [__]
because obviously the driving range is
kind of interesting and you were
obviously a young kid who came from a
serious area of La yeah got drafted into
the league I'm sure you dealt with a lot
of [__] I was just Guilty By Association
but I I mean I don't
I don't remember you know maybe off the
court but I don't
know on the court maybe I did you know
sometimes you get hyped you know what
I'm saying like anything happened but
obviously you you know you did a lot
back then you feel what I'm saying it
was a lot we did a lot back then and it
was a lot of you know if we had social
media back then everybody would be like
have horrible tarnish images you know
what I mean because it was just you know
back in the day like you could with no
camera phone so like whatever was
cracking you know right then and there
it was what was cracking like you have
to have a video person you have to tell
somebody bring a camera yeah you know
what I mean back then so you know a lot
of people was like not so much getting
in trouble like because I don't think
John Moret is in trouble you know what I
mean like he did some you know some
stupid [__] right but at the same time
like we've been doing like we've been
doing stupid [__] for the longest time a
long time
in a microscope yeah yeah
it's under a microscope because you know
I I was saying to uh just to my friends
man I'm you know I cried on my 25th
birthday I cried on my 30th birthday and
on my 35th birthday I was like damn dude
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna actually
live you know what I mean and so just
thinking about you know that Journey
from the time I got drafted to the time
I hit 30 was just it was just a lot